Hello! If you are new to this channel,
Ms. Coffee Bean sends her warm welcome!
Otherwise, nice to see you again!
In this video, we will discuss the latest research
trends around the question of where natural
language processing, or short: NLP, is heading to
and how to really achieve language understanding.
“You can’t learn language from the radio”. Why
not? Not even from the l huge amounts of text
on the Internet like GPT-3 had access to?
No, not even then. If you want to know why,
look at our previous video on this, linked below,
where we discuss why a model trained on text only
cannot really understand meaning,
but it can fake it really well.
So, what do we need to learn language?
This paper answers this question by setting up a
road map in five levels called the "World Scope".
The World Scope 1 is: The Corpus. A
long time ago, even before I was born,
the people in NLP where trying to
exhaustively annotate clean corpora of
natural language. These corpora were
first used to reconstruct the language
structure (like syntax trees)
then to build word vectors,
first not contextualized like word2vec
(where Apple and apple are the same),
or contextualized word embeddings, computed
dynamically depending on the context.
Do these representations really capture meaning?
The core assumption on the corpus level is that
context gives the words their meaning.
And it is a very plausible assumption.
When someone asks Ms. Coffee
Bean what “coffee” is,
she can use other words to answer:
“a hot drink made from the roasted and
ground seeds (coffee beans)”, and so on.
Word embeddings (like the ones from neural
networks trained on text) are doing the
same thing, defining words in relationship
to other words: word vectors do not mean
anything by themselves, but get their meaning in
relationship to the other words and their vectors,
through vector distances. But what is the
limitation of defining words with other words?
Let's say, for example, that
we do not know what the word
“seed” means? Then Ms. Coffee Bean can
define it further in terms of other words,
like “bean” and this you can define again
in term of other words, like “kidney”.
What is a kidney? A bean-shaped organ.
What is a bean? A kidney-shaped seed.
I hope you see the point: Sooner or later one
runs into big tautologies, when you define word
A in terms of word B and word B in terms of word
A. The whole assumption of giving meaning through
context basically floats in the air, where
words help each other up towards meaning,
but none of these words do
stand themselves on a ground.
Then what might a suitable ground for
this whole floating construction be? Think
about how much clearer things might become if
I would show you also a picture of coffee while
giving a definition about it. But images have no
place in the corpus era of NLP, shooo, go away!
And here we are, at the second World Scope:
The Internet. In the era of the Internet,
the NLP field has been able to make their
corpora so much bigger through web-crawling,
that only the Internet bandwidth,
the GPUs and energy are the limit!
Huge amounts of text make it much easier to
think that context gives meaning to words:
Language models like GPT-3 can see
so many words in so many contexts,
one might not even notice that the
words do not stand on a real ground
and that the language models
are only faking understanding.
But we do notice that the impressive
results of the last months with GPT-3
are not that of a big step towards
natural language understanding: How?
Even when important steps are being made
in data sizes and neural network sizes,
only a comparably little gain is
obtained in simple tasks for humans:
For example coreference is still a huge problem.
So, the era of the internet has shown us,
that size does matter to solve certain tasks,
but this cannot lead us to the goal
of understanding natural language.
What to do? We might consider calling the images
back. Images? Hey, come back here! Please!
So here we are at World Scope 3: Perception.
Ah, it's multimodal NLP! Ms.
Coffee Bean’s favorite level!
On this level, perception in form of images
and sounds comes to aid the NLP journey towards
understanding. It should help us in the many
cases where world knowledge together with the
assumption that we all see and hear the same
world events, makes us leave things unwritten,
unexplained. If Ms. Coffee Bean says:
“Okay, bye! I go have a sip of coffee now”,
we all have a good intuition
why she leaves to drink coffee:
She is tired, needs the caffeine and likes
the taste of coffee. [OH, that's strange!]
We know this, without it being
explicitly said. But a purely
text-based model could never learn
this if is never written anywhere.
Grounding words in their physical appearance in
images, would surely help a machine translation
model to learn that a ball and “o minge” are
the same thing but in different languages.
So we have seen that there is a lot of
motivation for multimodal learning to
marry the field of NLP with other amazing fields
like Computer Vision or Audio Signal Processing.
All this has led to great progress on
tasks that require language grounding
like Visual Question and Answering,
Visual Commonsense Reasoning,
image captioning, multimodal machine translation,
and so on. For more details exactly on this area,
check out Ms. Coffee Bean’s playlist on Multimodal
learning, linked in the description below.
World Scope 3 is great: we gear up
Machine Learning models with perception,
which helps a lot to observe things.
But can we go even one step further?
What if sometimes we must wait too long
for something to happen to observe it?
We as humans would then interact
with the system and trigger the event
that helps us gather more observation.
Could we also build this into our models?
Why not? And hereby we are already on
the Level 4 of understanding: Embodiment.
This means that by taking actions with a
physical body, the system could trigger
situations by itself, observe these, and
act again based on the triggered events.
We would have a model that would experience
how things act similarly and learn new words.
While this sounds awesome, it opens a huge pandora
box of yet unsolved problems: when to explore new
situations and when to learn more about the
current one? How to plan a set of actions?
How to react, like how to move a muscle?
How to translate these new experiences and
interactions into language? Does an experience
even need verbalization or is it of common sense?
Now let’s move on to the top level, to
World Scope 5: The Social World. While
in the stages before the model would have
learnt how to acquire data to have a good
understanding of the world in relation to the
model itself, it still does have any incentive
to communicate or use natural language
that it understands, in the first place!
Interpersonal communication is the most
important usage of natural language and it
also makes the most important test for AI:
The Turing’s Imitation Game. Only after an
agent has learnt to use language to affect the
world by social interaction it has understood
not only the meaning of language, but how
to use this meaning to change the world!
But while these five stages stand apparently
separated with research doing well in stages
1 and 2, well enough in stage 3 and
only baby steps in steps 4 and 5,
one has to also understand
how interdependent they are:
While chatbots are a thing nowadays,
we could argue that we are already
making huge progress in the 5th social
stage. But that is just quite not true.
While the system is apparently
socializing with the user,
it has no understanding about the communication
situation, about the user and his feelings.
Then the chatbot does also not know at all
about what utterances are hurtful in general
and which ones are hurtful only for specific
persons and playful in other social situations.
The real stage 5 can not be reached
without having modelled the previous
stages of perception and embodiment well enough.
So this was it: Ms. Coffee Bean’s shortened
and simplified version of the of this paper’s
story. If she made you curious enough, you
can also read the full paper by yourself.
As always, find the link in the description below.
Do not forget to like and subscribe
and share out the content if you want
to support Ms. Coffee Bean. Okay, bye!